investor optimism about the Trump
administration's coronavirus proposals
lifted world markets overnight after
yesterday's historic losses all three of
Wall Street's major indexes plunged more
than seven percent on Monday the Dow is
more than two thousand point drop is a 1
day record Nicky batiste is outside the
New York Stock Exchange for us Nicky
good morning so is this freefall likely
to continue or slow good morning Tony
well experts have warned the odds of a
possible recession have increased but
the president's potential stimulus
package has contributed to futures
rising by more than four percent today a
respite for anxious investors it comes
after the stock market suffered its
worst losses since the financial crisis
of 2008 Congress would have to approve
any payroll tax proposal by the
President and president Trump is also
discussing paying hourly employees
missing work over the coronavirus both
measures were received well by markets
which have made significant gains and
futures trading at this hour
crude oil prices also inch backed up
overnight after plunging to their lowest
levels since 1991 the drop comes as
Russia feuds with Saudi Arabia over its
oil production
if Wall Street sees another day of major
losses we could be looking at a bear
market by closing that happens when
stocks fall more than 20 percent from
their recent peak the last prolonged
bear market happened during the
financial crisis in 2008 and 2009 when
US stocks fell by more than half
Tonie everyone's reading against that
Nicki thank you very much